No
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm pretty gold it felt really good hey
to beacons of health right here come at
you guys this is Jared sleeper if you
don't know you should know he's been on
my channel acted on my podcast been on
my music together a lot of things I
brought him into this video today
because he's the closest I have to a
friend that's a health expert fitness
expert ticket so we actually
legitimately tried to make a workout
routine yeah I think it's a very
professional workout tape yeah literally
just press play and do what we do we've
built in rests for you yeah 30 seconds
on 30 off yeah we also tell a story yeah
exactly
exactly we should do ice dancing
actually basically it's gonna start with
getting a phone call on your fitness and
it's gonna be like ring ring are you
there and you'd be like hold on a second
I am the video this is the video yeah I
know so that happened I've literally if
you just press play on this and did it
along three times that's a workout
truly for fitness and lifestyle is all
about balance and if you want to balance
out this Fitness video is a completely
gluttonous video go over to ClevverTV
because
I know it's been so silent for the last
like hour in my yard and literally every
single noise that could happen is
happening right now you want to see
something pretty gluttonous go watch
Jarrett and I over on clever TV on cheat
day we just ate a ton of cake lot of
cake follow Jarrett oh I'm Jarrett
underscore sleeper on Instagram oh and
check out D 20 strike yes we're at the D
20 gram that's the other thing to really
quickly do 20 is a company that you and
your brothers and others have started
that focus on fitness and like only
especially for like other people like us
who are gamers and nerds yeah or anybody
who just sits at a computer a lot its
nerd Fitness yeah you can do it too
other than that I don't know